Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome back to One Shot.
Niko, I'm back! I'm sorry.
"Hey Markiplier, welcome back"
Oh thank you !
and welcome you guys back to One shot.
Now, we just got our
necessary tool of the library access card
and I don't know if we've combined
it with our photo. I don't think we have
and we're gonna put those.
...I can't combine those.
Can I do this?
Which I - oh fuck!!
Did I do something bad?
Everything still okay?!!
Ok, everythings fine
and glitter.
Okay!
So now this sticky
and I can plop that on that one.
"The card has my face on it now"
So it's now "Kip"s library card
so I'm pretty sure
That we can take this and we can take it all the way to the library.
Which means that we're gonna be able to do everything
that we needed to do to be able to get
through the library and meet
"the head Librarian"
Now I don't know who the head Librarian is,
but I'm hoping that they're gonna help solve the mystery of this book that
we have in our possession.
Now if there are other things that I've missed.
I don't think there are, because I think I
explored just about every territory.
I even went back and I met with the person who built
Silver out in the Barrens.
And Silver...
is the robot that was based on that scientist and
probably one of the first ones to be tamed by
whoever is the "author"
Not me, not my old character "the author"
But the author of these books
Alright, thank you.
mjeeeeeh who's gonna know
I mean could I have known? Do I have anything that could have done that?
I got a feather.
No ink for it so I guess that's fine.
Alright, Ms. Kip coming through.
Don't mind me.
I've no idea where this is gonna lead me.
ooo
Hello
"It's full"
of GARRBAGE
"Looks like an old phone."
huh
"A small tree."
Well what do we have to say about all this?
Ok, alright then, Kip coming through.
Hello.
I've got a book!
Mr. Markiplier here has got a book for YOU.
There's also one sticking out here.
"A book is poking out from the shelf."
Oh, well, that's nice.
But, I'm gonna get to those in just a second
because I've got this strange journal that I'm going to see if she knows.
"Here"
I found it in a pile of dirt next to some robot skulls
It was great.
"We found it in a safe!"
"Right, Markiplier?"
YEEAAAAHH...
Don't mention me in public!
*fake yawns*
" 'Scuse me"
Aww, aren't you sweet?
Thank you so much!
A book
sketchbook of some sort.
Ohhh~
So this is from Kiiiiiiip?
I think that's from Kip.
A book poking out.
"Hey I think this book is actually about clovers."
Ohhh!
That's a little weird.
Why are these things here and why are they so hardy?
That's bizarre.
A bok-a book is poking out
Oh.
Well that's sad.
So the prophet is dead.
The prophet is long gone.
'Scuse me
Black clover on the book.
Ah.
That's not a trooper that's... inhuman.
Ah, good.
Fridge is full of bottled water, takeout.
Ok, you repeated yourself there.
Printer
Computer says something about updated databases.
Small bed.
"I guess she lives here."
Ah, nothing really to see here.
Huh.
"Even the painting is books.'
Ah, that's sad.
Uh
OH!!
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY ABOUT THAT!
I'm not emotionally attached to anything going on here.
Oh, but it's...
It's time to go to bed.
Blank papers.
Full of manuscripts.
Blank papers and a book on the ground.
Whaaaaaaaaat?!!
Whaaat?!
You saying something to me?
What are you talking about here?
What are you talking about?
AHH!!
"I'm a little tired from walking."
Yeah, take a nap.
And GONE!
EVERYTHING'S GONE!
GONE AWAY!
Aww my GOOODD!
AW, YOU'RE SO CUUUUTE!
Uh-oh.
What is that?
An egg?
That seems weird.
WO-OH
Scared?
Oh, that ain't no egg.
Sorry.
Uh-oh.
Nightmare?
Yes.
Skewy...
"Come on, let's go."
Aw, come on, YOU CAN TALK ABOUT IT, NIKO.
Just don't let that lightbulb drop away!
It's the lifeline of everything in this place.
Huh.
Wo-ah fuck
The author?!
Cuz I'm so smart, right?
Everybody trusts me cuz I am the smart one.
IT'S YOUR EYEBALLS!
*sound of Ripping an eye off* (Pffftz...)
BLEGM
Actually it might be-
-Oh! Good, it's not my eyes...
Ohoho
Nice!
Well, ok, thank you!
Glad I don't have to rip my eyes out.(laughing)
Because, they're glowing yellow.
Alright so where do we go from here?
We have what we need.
We have three pieces to bring of the
quote-unquote old sun back if that's what that really is.
But then, where do we go?
Because I need to figure something else out here-
Yes
Taken a lot of naps but no food.
I guess, yeah!
I think? Yeah!
I'm assuming, yes?
Huh.
So that means we're gonna go back up the elevator.
So I guess that tells me enough where I'm supposed to go after this.
I think I've explored all that there is for here.
I've talked to pretty much everybody.
But I'm-I'm
still wondering what it means by it said...
"It's been guiding me all along"
What does it mean by that?
Like...
Is it talking about the red blocks and whatnot because
the red blocks first appeared when I opened that safe
and found that book.
So either the spirit is this author guy that everyone seems to enjoy so much,
to describing its own world to this whole people.
"M-HM"
THAT'S WHAT MARKIPLIER LIKES:
SILENCE!
DON'T TALK TO NOBODY AND DON'T LET NOBODY TALK TO YOU.
That's how I like it.
But first, before I go anywhere else, I'm gonna check on this plant.
Cuz a lot of you guys were worried about this plant and I know,
I...
And a lot of people were saying that you need to try the sun on it but I did try that so,
It wasn't that. I think it might've just been a time thing.
But I also have this enchanted water!
And with this enchanted water, may be
I might be able to water with that and then it'll never need water again.
But may be, this medicated water...
Sploosh!
Splah-du-see!
"It sprouted a tiny leaf!"
Ohh!~
Ok, now I'm gonna try this.
Ok, so... pzz... the Sun ain't working, but now!
It's sprouting because apparently it never need water again.
Ain't that a handy-dandy thing for a plant?
Looks like Maize is going back to being strong.
So, either...
Either the spirit of this world is...
the... the pixelated blockiness,
or, it is this Author, unless they're the same thing, I don't know.
Or, it could be...
whatever this taming process is. Ok, now bear with me. That's a bit more of a stretch, but bear with me.
This taming process, no one really understands it, but it's the thing that makes robots seemingly able to... be human.
That's a little weird, you know? You gotta admit that it's a little weird.
Tha-That's not my first option but that's why it's my third one, but it's *inaudible mumble*
I'M STARVING!! Give me free food!
PANCAKES! YES!
Oh hell yeah!
Ohh~
Aww~
*inhales*
I don't think Niko's gonna be able to get home. *Sigh*. Uhm...
I sometimes forget that this is just a kid.
Like, this is legitimately, this is just a kid!
This kid is here, and for what reason? Plucked out of his home...
for nothing else than to save this world that apparently doesn't want to be saved.
Like this world seemingly is ready to die.
By all accounts, the inhabitants are just like...
There're some people that are struggling, like the scientists are trying to figure out what they're doing.
I don't know.
"You need to find a way to get to the library on the surface."
Well, I've already did that, so I'm just gonna go and see what's going on with the plant,
see if it's sprouted anymore.
I don't know if it would of.
And I don't know what it's gonna do if it does.
Nope, that's all there is, and there's really nothing else to do.
Cuz I got the glowing amber, the glowing dice, the glowing... feather.
Huh, weird.
So, all this yellow phosphor that they called it, is like, as close to the original that they have.
Blue phosphor being out the Barren, green phosphor in the Glen,
and then red phosphor here in the city.
So, I guess the only way to go is to...
make my way to the tower. I don't even think that I can take a nap anymore.
Cuz I mean considering I've just got one, so I'm just basically stalling time.
"We should get going now, Markiplier." Ok, I get it.
I just feel so bad for Niko.
What's gonna happen to him?
Where he's gonna go?
I mean, he's gonna go to the tower, obviously. But where he's gonna go?
...oh, this is quiet now...
*elevator sounds* Clunk, lalala~
You better not say a word, Niko.
You know I demand silence!
Not a, not a peep
"m-hm!"
What was that? Huh?
Better not said nothing to me.
Alright, fine.
Oh, ok.
Ok. Ok, then. Good, silence. As I requested.
Ok, so now, where do I go? What do you have to say?
Huh. "You alright?" The messiah.
Oh, yeah, this is the same thing.
Ugh. Yeah, it's the same thing that he said before.
So, I don't remember if there's anyway to directly took me to the tower was.
I know there were those doors that were locked from the inside like that one just down there.
But I don't think that's where I'm supposed to go.
So, I'm gonna carry through the alleyways here, and hopefully  I'll find something that leads me to where I need to go.
There was that bed... in here that supposedly someone lived in these alleyways.
And I don't know if they're here yet.
"A big book." "Says 'understanding robots'."
I don't know why anyone would be here understanding robots.
There's a note. "Thank you for working so hard, Mr. Lamplighter."
Then that's all there is
So, I guess what we gotta do... Oh, and there's that robot that was trapped.
Just like trapped in this.
Like the glowing... greyness.
P#L.%%EAS;E DO NO//T APPR#OACH!
UHG!
this is so wierd, if that's the spirit of the world
maybe its like...
maybe its like that's in its death rose
it can't...
it can's seem to live anymore-
AND WHAT'S THAT TREE ABOUT?!
Why is that tree there?!
there's a lot of mysteries in this game
And I feel like I may have missed here and there, but..
other than that, I've been pretty throughout about it
at least as far as my Expertise goes
so I guess the only Place to go
is try to get to the Tower.
Wherever that it.
so I'll be Right back When I find it
Wow!
WOW!!
OKAY, that opened up!
I didn't expect that too
but I guess this is gonna leave me to the tower?
Maybe...
The music is Lovely here
hello?...
is there someone in the Darkness? Waiting for Me?
ohh, Is That the Tower?
OMG, that is, isn't it?
that's just the Freaking Tower! it's right there!
maybe I shouldn't call it "the Freaking Tower"
it's...seems to be awfully nice
there's nothing hidden back there
OK
sooo...do I just Walk in?
I...guess I do
what else would I do?!
where does this leave, though?
I-I wanna find out
OH! maybe this-
uhh...
uhh?
UHH!! that let me to the door
the one I just come and about.
before the alleyway
OK, so I guess all that I need to do
is just I need to go in to the...
The Tower and and
I don't know, my Instincts is just like, save and like
try to, try to do this right, but I only got-
WHOA!
X?!
X!!
I'm "Xsing" as hard can
what do I X?
I'm trying to X!
Nope, okey, Allright then
OH!
do you-you're talking about
yo-you're talking about THIS X? the one that closes out the program?
it does get Red!
uh
ooooooooooohhhhhhh....
uuuuuhhhhhHHHHH
OH!
HEY!
HI!
What the Hell is happening?
AH!
Hello!
oh-uh, dark...
so I understood-ed correctly, I was support to exit out of that.
oh-uh, niko-
I'm here niko!!
I'm right here - oh don't break my heart like this.
oh,geez.
oh no
can I move?
I can
I got NO items.
where's niko?
where's nikoo?!
whou!
hello!
HI!
Hello!
NO!
that's a goddamn lie!
no! I'm here!
well, this doesn't seem right, someone get IT down here right NOW!
alright, I have a funny feeling that bed is probably the last thing I need to do
I need to wander around and find an answer to this!
cuz there some fishy going on and-
oh god no...
oh-uh
OH-UH!
AW SHIT!
well...
I got nothing..
I can't fast travel
I didn't even know that I could fast travel
apparently I really can
so is this the only option?
:(
WHOOU!...okay
HEY, HOW ABOUT YOU DON'T TELL ME WHAT TO DO, OKAY?!
HOW ABOUT YOU DO THE OP- I'M COMING BACK IN!
UH!
Not Going to leave Niko behind like that!
whooooAAAAAkey!
MY DESKTOP CHANGED!
OH!
the computer is the identity, DUH! why didn't I think of that?
OK, now we're getting in the thick of this!
hazzahh!
ah shit...ok
so that's active!
I got that up now!
so now I just  gotta go back to One Shot, Right?!
I think
HEY!
it's a dream...
oh...oh-uh!
yeah, it's me!
I'm here, niko!
I'M HERE!!
!!I'M RIGHT HERE NIKO!!!
what do you have, niko?!
a clover...
Ahh!
I've got a clover that ain't so black no more.
What did I do? that's creepy!
oh, YOU knew! you knew that I do, is that it?
well I like that a lot less.
ok.
WAAAAIIIIIIT a minute!
wait a minute!
oh. OK. alright. OK, so we got- we got something new here now.
so we got that note, this note here.
there's something cut out of it and Niko is in the middle of God-knows-where.
whooaa that's weird.
WHOOAA that's super weird!
ah-OH...wait!
wait...wait
is there like-
OMG!
please tell me this is how this works!
PLEASE tell that's how that works!
OH-wait..NO. if I do this...
OMG!
please tell me that's how that does!
OH
what the hell happened? WHOA-some Changed!
WHOA!
ah
OK.
put that over that-Apologies for that! I did not want to put the Librarian in Danger.
so what you're saying is...
the only way to go is UP!
once that's there. that's what that means!
the only way to go is up!
uh...OK- Alright then.
hipididpiedipidubidubu-OMG!
now we're getting in the Thick of this!
so the only way to go out is up here as well.
oh...is that so?
well
I'm about to be a learning individual.
and you are gonna tell all your secrets, that's what you're gonna do.
I HAVE seen it happen to dear friends
and the overlay is telling me to go to the right.
you got it, Buddy Bu. I'm on the Way.
oh hello
ah-are you talking about me or Niko here?!
ok
Good God, this is getting so cool.
OK, so the only way to get out is just go back just the way I came.
alright, you got it.
oh alrighty then.
and who are you? are you the AUTHOR?!
you're the author?!
are you the author about this?!
you the author about this whole thing?!
maybe?!
let's see
I see
ok th-that seemed-the pictures are a little more jagged in this one.
Oh Hello!
Oh
so, are you something about the "identity" as well
I'm assuming  this is the Author here. and I'm assuming
that there is something l-
whoa!
ok
but now...
what ONE thing?
I'm guessing your pointing to the right door there.
so I'm gonna go in that one.
yeeah baby!
as in the identity wants to die?
really?
that's sad.
whoa
yeah, I have.
whoa...this is heavy shit.
ah man.
wait wait, which one was that?
ok...got it
geez
so that's what everybody meant that this world was dying!
they were all felling it.
if that's the spirit of this world
then every inhabited would feel, that death is approaching.
and then there's the-there's like-
the darkness that you would feel about it.
why is this "identity" desire death?
I just Wanted to be a silly GOD that shouted a lot! I didn't want this kind of responsibility.
oh god.me oh me no. oh God!
me
in that door?
ahhh...NOO!
uuhhhhhh
you know what that means! instant curse-pluscion!
instant curse-plu-Wait. oh
there's a secret door?
oh, there's a secret door down there, isn't there?
no? oh ok, it wasn't a secret door.
................
......................
what's not that simple? what are you talking about?!
this is not the Author giving me instructions anymore?
what are you talking about?
ok, so there's a puzzle going on here
soory-don't know what to do in situations like this.
oh I-
I did the wrong one-never mind-I'm Dumb! I thought there was another.
ok, well I mean, if you do, you do:
shubabababababba blam!!
done and done!
I don't know what that did
oohhhh.....NOOO!!
OH DON'T PUT THAT RESPONSIBILITY ON ME!!!
oh no-shssssissvavavavvavavav
blalbllbla...blabllbalablbla
Blim! ok
so that's what that means!
so if I wanna save this world, I would trap Niko here.
oh boy.
ah don't put that on me!!
oh DON'T DO THAT!
don't do that
don't do that- Oh no.
oh no
OK got that!
ohh nnooOO NO!
AHH!!
its the SUN!
ah...NO!
Niko
whoa
ok, I was- I was waiting for you Niko There!
alright then- what in the hell?
oh no, where am I- Am I in that basement Again?!
oh I AM!
I don't-ahahahah
how did I get back here?!
How did I get back here?!!
Oh I am back here, but before got decrapped
well that's...colorful.
my favorite channels, I guess
I keep that one, I guess
well damn!, everything here is Fine
man this is so wierd
and here's..This place!
yeah, you won't talk-
ad infinitu-
ad FINITUM!
not "ad infinitum"... "ad Finitum"
which I believe "ad infinitum" is
forever or infinity(to infinity) but ad finitum means...
probably "only once" or something like that.(to the end)
my big eyes...
you haven't gotten in the bathroom either, Niko.
you holding that amazing blarer
is it from the sun outside?
is that a thing that's happening?
okay, that's creepy.
I don't that's how I save the world...
hmm...
jiggly jiggle
yeah, I kinda did, he really did, yeah!
eyah, it's-it's it's a doosy.
a a-a -a Game! is that what your're trying to say?
...it hasn't been tamed...
oh
well that's a-that's a doosy.
yeah, of course I'll tell Niko the truth.
yeah, you gotta give what you gotta give 'em,
what does Niko want?
why is it on me? what does Niko want to do?
like that' the important thing-Alright!
I'm Banning My Decree!
of NO talking in the elevator!
I got something important to tell you, Niko!!
YEAH...I would like to say something to you!
Yes! I would-I-I!
ah...
what would happen if you just didn't tell 'em?!!
that'd be Hooorrible!!
(sigh)
oh...NOOO!
NIKO, WHAT DO YOU WANT?- it's not MY choice, It's YOURS!
OH! this-
GOD!
FRREEEAAK!
freaky-di-do-da! freaky-di-Dick- OH boy!
ohhhh NOO!!!
(away-from-camera depression scream)
jus need to do-just to get some Stress out!!
WHAT DO I DO???!!
WHAT DO I DO?!!! I JUST WANTED TO BE A SCREAMING GOD!!!
AHHH!! that was the lifes of the many out way-the life of the FEW!!
it's hard to even tel if this world is real...
but I don't think that matters...because...
the "Identity"has said that it can't go against its programming and he's trying to say:
"you do realize what this world is..."
in terms of reality, I think the game is trying to show you that Niko is a real
Thing...A Person...
bu also, this seems to be inhabited with...people
and also robots that are starting to figure out who they are- you know what I mean?!
so it's a hard conundrum...
is this a situation where the need of the many out way the needs of the few-what is gonna happen to Niko...
if he returns the sun?
does that mean that Niko would be trapped here..forever?!
torn away from his family
without a choice
why..WHY? that's the main question on my mine. why...
why...was Niko torn from his family?
what IS this world that pulls people in to DO this
and Why does the "identity" want to Die?!
is ti because that when that sun goes into that...
Tower...it's gonna-POWER everything
but is a Horrible machine that robs the life from random children plucked from different universes.
is that an engine worth continuing?
for the people that live here..
maybe
there-there are arguably...millions and millions of people.
all banking on this messiah being able to save..them!
the savior...you know..
if I-I'm gonna act
I'm gonna do this as in I was in this situation
if I were in this situation, even if it was a world that I wasn't apart of
but a world that I travel through and I met people that  seemed...good hearted and
and and well meaning and families
that are torn apart by the Darkness and this world is consuming itself.
if I were in that situation, I would put the light bulb in.
no question about it...I'm not Niko though
Niko has a Family, Niko has a family that he misses very dearly and his friends and his hometown.
and it was unfair that he was ripped here,but...
GOD, I have to do what I would do in that situation which, I would return the sun, I would put it in there.
I don't know what that means for Niko, but, that's what I have to do.
it's what I have to do
I didn't wanna help...
ah, Niko is such a good kid
OH!!!
its just gave me an Achievement for re-birth.
and that's it?!!!!
oh! please tell there's something
is there something I could do
NOOO!!!
OH NO is it-if I open the game, is ti just gonna go with that one?
is gonna go with that same see-OH GOD NO!!
OH that's the END!!!
ffffffffFUCK!
hhhmmmm
ah!
so you do have a conundrum either way
'cuz, if you save Niko and send him back, 'cuz I'm assuming that Niko Died.
if you send him back, he has to live forever with the guilt of destroying that entire world.
ahhhh!!!
ahhhhh!!!!!!!!
ok, I'm emotionally devastated-I need to go lay down
ahh Fuck!!
oh,boy, alright-so that is the end of One Shot
I hope I did OK...
I hope I did...I don't know if I did, I don't know if I did
ahhh my GOD!!!
ah MY MEEE!!!!!- ah Fuck, OK so
that's-that's it-there's no more.
it ended just as quickly as it begin
so Thank you Everybody so Much for Watching-if you wanna play this game for your self...
I imagine there are different choices to be made through out it!
different choices with...infinite more meanings.
than what you saw here
and secrets and noxin cronies that you could explore, I bet
and a Beautiful story to be told.
man, that was so beautiful
and that's all I have to say about it. I'll let the experience speak for itself-there's no words that I could put here to, either, comfort you
or explain more what's happened, it's something that
is what it is, simply for the choices that you make and that in it of itself its..
beautiful is it's simplicity, so
Thank you so Much for Watching
and as always
I will see YOU
in the next video
bye-BYE!